vous étiez nombreux dans les rues ce
week end à tours pour la réouverture des
magasins depuis le second confinement à
moins d'un mois de noël c'est le moment
de vérité pour les commerçants nombre
d'entre eux seront ouverts les dimanches
de décembre
le reportage d'hélène chapelet après un
mois de rideaux baissés pour cause
d'épidémie il est enfin possible de
rouvrir boutiques et de remettre des
bijoux en vitrine
dans ce commerce tourangeau depuis 80
ans ont créé des bagages sur mesure en
fonction des envies et des attentes du
client au moins de novembre
aucun chiffre d'affaires n'a pu être
réalisée car dans son secteur d'activité
le click and collect n'est pas adapté il
était donc temps de reprendre nos
clients viennent chez nous pour des
bijoux particulier ils veulent voir ils
veulent essayer ils veulent comprendre
quelle est la qualité du diamant pied
dessus te fait de nos doigts etc
quand on peut pas vendre une bague à
1000 2000 où il fut pris
click and collect la payer puis il a
cherché sans d'ouvrir la porte 2020
amputé de trois mois d'activité est une
année noire pour tous les commerçants
tous espèrent tout de même réalisé un
bon mois de décembre
dans cette boutique indépendante de
jouer c'est un marathon qu'ils
commencent puisque le commerce restera
ouvert sept jours sur sept jusqu'au 24
décembre pour tous les gens qui ont qui
ont fait le choix de ne pas commander
sur internet de ne pas céder à la
facilité mais la contrepartie c'est que
nous il faut qu'on soit là pour eux
aussi
et donc ça implique d'avoir la boutique
ouverte quoi qu'il en soit tous les mois
de décembre la boutique est toujours
ouverte 7 jours sur 7
mais là on commence dès maintenant et
puis avec voilà une amplitude horaire un
peu plus importante
il faut qu'il faut que tout le monde
puisse faire sa liste du père noël donc
il faut aider tout le monde
oui il suffit d'enlever le petit film à
l'arrière d'accord vader directement la
surface très bien on est tranquille on
est sûrs de la raison
quel magasin ici saperlipopette qui
vivent les mêmes produits que je peux
trouver sur internet j'ai privilégié
parce qu'on est dans une des démarches
un petit peu d'engagement vis-à-vis de
nos commerçants qu'on veut soutenir dans
cette période un petit peu difficile
pour eux et puis en même temps avoir en
plus le conseil et puis l'expertisé des
commerçants et pour aider ces
commerçants à passer ce cap difficile
la préfecture vient de les autoriser à
rester ouvert tous les dimanches jusqu'à
la fin de l'année et tous les soirs
jusqu'à 21h